bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission les
petits bricoleurs aujourd'hui je veux
montrer comment réaliser une petite
voiture à partir de rouleau de papier de
toilette pour réaliser cette petite
voiture nous avons besoin d'un rouleau
de papier de toilette des pics de
brochettes des bouchons tourne vis de la
gouache un pinceau et un petit peu d'eau
de la colle une petite chute de papier
un feutre des ciseaux et un morceau de
ficelle alors donc on va prendre le
rouleau de papier on voit le plier
légèrement comme ça reprendre une tour
de vis on va perforé la à ce niveau-là a
repris un centimètre de la pliure faut
faire attention
las comme ça tu es de l'autre côté
pareil à peu près un centimètre de la
mort ont fait à peu près dans le même
alignement
voilà donc ça fait ça il faut que ce
soit dans le même alignement et ensuite
on va le perdre
bon je vais prendre le vert mais vous
prenez la couleur de votre choix vous
plaît aussi à l'intérieur
on va prendre le pic à brochette donc on
va casser ton morceau je vais casser les
deux manettes bonne grandeur
le volume être dans la fente up
ah ah
donc ça va donner ça on va passer de la
peinture aussi on va pas laisser ça
comme ça
voilà ce que ça donne la mènerai reste
plus qu'à mettre les roues alors donc
les roues c'est des bouchons donc on va
perforé le milieu donc toujours avec un
tournevis
vous faites juste la toile au milieu il
faut faire attention au faux pas se
blesser
donc on fait ça pour les 4 bush au loin
alors donc il reste plus qu'à mettre bas
les rouches
c'est l'époux du camino donc on va
mettre les roues dans ce sens là je
voulais dans ce sens là après on va
rajouter une petite terre après là on
peut réduire ainsi la tige est trop long
de les raccourcir
vous voulez rajouter une petite perle au
bout je veux faire joli voilà on va
rajouter une petite béraud
quatrième paire
et voilà alors maintenant on va rajouter
remettre un petit mot sur de ficelle
alors donc on va rajouter là
voilà c'est je fais rentrer petit peu
non
coop
après il suffit de décor et donc je
prends une petite chute de papier je
l'écoutais l'entrée du carré que je vais
le coller la pointe de caux
bon après je vais prendre le fameux
écrire le numéro un
voilà
alors la voiture est un terminée
j'ai fait d'autres modèles avec des
ronds de couleur différente avec des
gros nichons avec du papier avec le la
tâche parisienne à vous de laisser
parler votre imagination des mots je
vous dis à bientôt et à la prochaine
émission
au revoir